for more let's go now to dr ashish jha
he's dean of brown university school of
public health and a great person to talk
to on a confusing morning like this one
dr john good morning to you
simple question based on the publicly
available data does it appear that a
third shot is safe effective and above
all necessary
yeah good morning thanks for having me
back based on all the data that i have
seen all the data that's out there
i think people who are vulnerable people
who are older people with chronic
diseases immunocompromised they would
benefit from a third shot i think it is
necessary for that group for young and
healthy people i am far less convinced
that we need that third shot
from a public health messaging point of
view is it potentially counterproductive
for the biden administration to be
talking about shot number three when
tens of millions of americans are still
on shot number one
yeah it's you know it's a tricky thing
for the bite administration because on
one hand they obviously want to we all
want to get unvaccinated people
vaccinated because that is by far the
most important thing we can be doing but
there are older vulnerable people people
in nursing homes and elsewhere who
probably need that third shot and
they've got to prepare for that
population as well so it is a tricky
message but we've got to get both of
those messages out there it's tricky dr
jaw it's frustrating and dare i say a
little annoying is it very common for
the science community to disagree
it is common actually gail you know
what's funny is most people don't pay
attention to us when we disagree with
each other and uh it just happens to be
in a pandemic you're seeing it all spill
out into the open but this is science
you know reasonable people can look at
the same data and come to slightly
different conclusions or sometimes very
different conclusions
dr john i do have one other question
then on the on the subject of
disagreement there are some
epidemiologists and public health
experts who believe that the delta
variant is roaring through our country
and will leave in its wake a lot of
immunity and that could mean that we're
reaching some sort of a peak here where
the virus might decline and become more
manageable you agree
yeah i i do see the south the deep south
that has seen such a horrible surge over
the summer peaking and starting to come
down unfortunately there's so many parts
of the country with lots of unvaccinated
people that have not yet been hit as
hard by the delta variant and they
remain vulnerable the midwest the great
plains there are other places so we've
got to keep pushing on vaccinations
to prevent more spread of this virus
and you mentioned the mixed messaging
and we know that causes hesitation when
it comes to people getting their
vaccines um
where do you say we should go for a
trusted source so people can have the
right information
yeah so there are people who i also look
to to for verification of my own views
and who i think are really the leading
experts we all know the probably the
best one of them all is tony fauci who
has been a leader in this area for 30
plus years
cdc dr wolenski i think has been a
terrific public health leader for many
many years we have very good people in
our country that we can turn to for
advice and guidance
dr john thank you so much for that
valuable information we'll check in with
you a little bit later